[Music]
it's 1905 Northern California Frank
Epperson is 11 years old he's sitting on
his front porch making a sort of DIY
drink that's very popular at this time
he has just poured a sugary soda powder
into a glass of water and is mixing
enthusiastically with a wooden stir
stick we don't know exactly how the next
24 hours play out but we can imagine
that something catches Frank's attention
and he abandons his drink mid stir after
a cold Bay Area night
Franco rediscovered mixed drink the next
morning it's frozen solid but instead of
throwing it out Frank pulls the icy
block of soda out of the glass by the
embedded stir stick and in a moment of
vision liquid delighted by his invention
Frank begins making the frozen treat for
friends and as he grows older begins
selling them as EPSA khals a contraction
of his last name and the word icicle it
is rumoured that later
Frank's own kids does the icy delicacies
popsicles others claim the name is a
combination of lollipop and bicycles
regardless where the name comes from the
popsicle is here to stay approximately
two billion popsicles are sold feed here
[Music]
you